dangereux pour l'environnement et la
santé des humains tueur d'abeilles
certains pesticides font plus de mal que
de bien
le bull cédant qu'à briques pourvus que
ce soit un automatisme québec va donc
réglementer les pesticides les plus
nocifs encore utilisé sur les terres
agricoles et les interdire en milieu
urbain soit 3 néonicotinoïdes et le
chlorpyrifos des insecticides et
l'atrazine un herbicide les impacts
négatifs de ces produits ont été
amplement démontré des agronomes
certifié devront dorénavant prescrire
ces pesticides aux agriculteurs comme le
ferait un médecin pour un médicament ce
serait suffisant pour éviter que des
pesticides soit vendu inutilement qu'on
veut c'est qu'actuellement avec la
justification gagne les commandes aux
agronomes de monter pour les dossiers
avant que la persécution
ça sera documenté façon très précise
pour quoi grever leurs recommandations
les agriculteurs devront également
obtenir une certification pour utiliser
les pesticides tenir un registre et
respecter une distance minimale des
sources d'eau l'ensemble de ces mesures
pourrait leur coûter jusqu'à 450 $ par
année par agriculteurs pour les aider
québec promet 14 millions $ en cinq ans
mais il ya tout de même un
mécontentement watts une difficulté
supplémentaire à maintenir notre
compétitivité
la réaction des groupes environnementaux
est mitigé car les glyphosate mieux
connu sous le nom de round up peut
toujours être librement utiliser les
glissades figure parmi le top 10 des
substances les plus à risque au québec à
cause de son volume d'utilisation
l'épandage 4000 tonnes insecticides et
herbicides chaque année et bien
documenté mais l'emploi de semences
enrobées de pesticides les mois et
brouille les cartes
quand on parle de la semences enrobées
s'était pas perçu comme étant un
pesticide aujourd'hui là on change
vraiment on le caractérise
la ministre de l'environnement reconnaît
avoir pris ses décisions sans établir de
cibles précises pour réduire les
pesticides
elle nous explique que ce n'est qu'un
premier pas une transition ici mathieu
dion radio canada québec